hey guys I'm Ryan writes no this would
be crazy so we're gonna check out this
trailer um it's a mock trailer I believe
it has to be okay
Star Wars the Binks awakens its Jar Jar
Binks I guess included in the new Star
Wars movie so let's check it out because
everyone knows Jar Jar Binks is
everyone's favorite character from the
Star Wars
dude I [ __ ] every time I watch Star
Wars I'm always like man I wish it was
Jar Jar was in more of these movies
looks legit force is strong in my family
I had
my sister has
you have that power too
dr. side of the force is a pathway to
many abilities some consider
that's true
he's a park oh dude I started watching
this and like going what if he really
wasn't it and I started getting mad oh
maybe a cameo baby but not just watching
this joke video and then a little bit
later like adjusting to the joke it was
like so pissed off they threw him in
there you know okay here's like I say
yes he's pretty annoying yeah but yeah
for the first for episode one for that
whole tone of that whole movie that was
the only one where it would make sense
for Jar Jar to be in there his character
I can see why you know George Lucas
might have thought that character would
work for that one
I mean the whole city and yeah this is
very much like people are gonna love
this guy
what what makes me sad actually is for
the actor like in a genuine way because
that actor stuck was the first one to
really do motion capture right know like
going to this suit and then they CGI man
but it's really a performance yeah and
then no one liked it but then Gollum
comes out that's not true but I'll tell
you why because
immortal character everybody knows who
Jar Jar is yeah every doesn't have a
great reputation he's not supposed to be
a serious character but I know he makes
him but that's not the point is I'm
saying even though he's not a main
character he's really an annoying
character and nobody really likes them
despite that created an immortal
character okay yeah but that doesn't
disprove my point what I was trying to
say is when Gollum came out that actor
Andy Serkis got all this recognition as
if he was the first one to do that but
really it was this actor who started off
doing motion capture and then he never
really got work after this movie after
episode one it kind of bums me out that
like it sucks as I heard in interviews
of like Liam Neeson especially saying
like he did exactly
he was directed to do Wow so he he
didn't like [ __ ] up Jar Jar Binks like
he did exactly what the writing said to
do and what the directing was saying to
do it's sad because you know if there
was like better direction maybe or
better writing he'd have the career - of
doing motion capture but now that's
because the guy's black
it's racist [ __ ] you [ __ ] all
comes down to racism yeah it's because
Jar Jar Binks was played by a black guy
that's why the [ __ ] studio's don't
like him [ __ ] racist
was he really yeah didn't know that no
yeah well now you know cuz Studios like
to keep that [ __ ] hidden racist out
there try say studi other racist
Elizabeth yeah they are ones the last
time you saw an Armenian guy play a lead
in a movie anyway guys if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter
where if we get enough followers we get
product placement that's right people so
like phone cases it's great because it
protects your phone you know you never
know if you're gonna drop it or
sometimes you might be getting head and
then you're recording the girl doing it
and then you might drop the phone and
you know it might hit her head but if
it's just a phone it's gonna hurt her
head but what the case doesn't hurt as
much I know that from personal
experience
phone cases